لحظه انتهاء مباراه السعوديه والارجنتين
في كاس العالم كان اسم المملكه يتصدر
الترند العالمي على مختلف شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعيه وبكل لغات العالم لا حديث
لمليارات من البشر الا هذه البلاد التي
هزمت الاسطوره ليونيل ميسي ورفاقه
يحدث ذلك فيما تبذل المملكه جهودا على
مستويات عده للترويج لنفسها كوجهه عالميه
لسياحه ما يعطي لرواجر البلاد عالميا قيمه
ماديه يقدرها بعد خبراء التسويق ب 30
مليارنيات فمن اين اتى هذا الرقم
انا في التسويق عند شيء نسميه الاعلان
والاعلان المدفوع هذا واضح جدا حسبته ولكن
الاهم والاكثر كلفه وهو الاعلام المكتسب
او الارنب ميديا بمعنى اخر لو اردنا ان
نحدث نفس الاثر كم لازم ندفع الاحداث هذا
الاثر ال 30 مليار تعتبر حتى تتوقع متحفظ
الوصول لهذه النتيجه هو الاثر العظم اللي
ظهر في صوره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حكومه
ايه
الحدث يتخط الرياضه كره القدم صناعه تجتذب
استثمارات ب 100 مليارات دولارات وقوامها
الاساسيه الاعلان والترويش
وسعوديه بدات منذ سنوات مسيره الترويج
نفسها كوجهه سياحيه عالميه
فكيف تستفيد من التفات العالمي
للاستفاده من هذه الفرص في الترويج بشكل
اكبر للسياحه السعوديه لاحظنا ارتفاع في
البحث عن كلمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
او السعوديه من خلال محركات البحث من خلال
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا من
الاستفاده بهذه الفرصه اليوم مقيمين مجلس
دول التعاون الخليجي اللي موجودين في قطر
وباقي الدول ايضا حامل لبطاقه هي ممكن
الدخول للمملكه العربيه السعوديه تاشيره
سياحيه مجانيه خلال فتره المونديال هذه
كلها بتكون حافز وداعم لتطوير القطاع خلال
هذه الفتره معرفه اكبر عن السعوديه
وتعطيهم فرصه لزياره السعوديه مره واثنين
وثلاثه
النهوض الذي تشهده السعوديه منذ اطلاق
رؤيه 20 30 لا يتوقف عند القطاعات
الاقتصاديه بل يبني على النهوض بالموسيقى
والثقافه والرياضه التي تربط الشعوب
وسياحه هي القطاع الذي يدمج بينها جميعا
[تصفيق]